comienza a llegar a las casas la
publicidad electoral los candidatos
pueden mostrar sus clips de campaña y
sus fotografías van a ser colgadas en
unos paneles que están muy cerca de los
locales de votación hoy nuevamente hay
un estudio de opinión como casi todos
los dias angela y sigue mostrando la
tendencia de los últimos días es el
estudio de xevi of y la fundación junior
es muestra al presidente manuel macro
con la mejor preferencia para la primera
vuelta un 28 por ciento de los votos sin
embargo por tercera semana consecutiva
en descenso en segundo lugar a la
candidata de extrema derecha marine
lepén que por su parte ya monta o sube
en las preferencias por tercera semana
consecutiva llegando un 17,5 por ciento
y como ya lo ha mostrado otros estudios
de opinión en las últimas semanas en
tercer lugar se ubica el candidato de
izquierda jean luc mélenchon con 14 por
ciento de las preferencias también
subiendo por tercera semana consecutiva
angela lo más importante de este estudio
es la cantidad de personas que no está
segura de ir a votar en primera vuelta
es muy alta y se teme una abstención
rompa el récord de hace 10 años
justamente cuando un 28% de las personas
de los electores franceses no fue a
votar en primera vuelta se creía
justamente porque está esta elección no
tiene como gran misterio ya que se asume
que el presidente manuel macro no sería
electo fácilmente al menos pasaría a una
segunda vuelta fácilmente y se repetiría
el escenario del 2017